inflation down a tad but still in double
figures yeah and crucially considerably
higher than the bank of England's two
percent Target so we've got some work to
do to get it down but it is coming down
and it looks like it has peaked you
might remember 11.1 was the inflation
figure back in October yeah so it's come
down considerably the new figure it's
10.1
economists thought it would come down to
just 10.3 percent but crucially it's in
line with the bank of England's own
forecast of 10.1 percent so it looks
like they've got it right so far and
inflation is falling just in line with
how they were expecting it to do now
what's caused this well falling
wholesale Energy prices
falling transport prices especially
airfares have been coming down that's
all filtered through into lower
inflation
unfortunately food prices are still
stubbornly high close to their highest
level since the 1970s which isn't good
news for anyone during their weekly shop
but 10.3 it means that the bank of
England could soon start slashing
interest rates it's been rising raising
them quite a lot recently
most people in the financial markets
think the bank has one or two more rate
Rises to go before it starts bringing
rates down but this data suggests they
might be able to stop sooner than that
okay for now thanks very much indeed
well joined now by the chief economic
advisor at Alliance and that's Mohamed
El Aryan hello to you thanks for joining
us on the program this morning much
appreciated
um so we're still in double figures what
is there to be um content about this
morning
um there's two things to be content
about inflation is coming down and it's
coming down faster than the market
expected but having said that as we just
heard it remains too high at 10 percent
means that up purchasing power is 10
smaller than it was a year ago it is
sticky it's not coming down fast enough
and it's hitting the poor particularly
hard when food prices go up by over 16
percent that is really bad news for
those unlimited budgets
yeah what is it I was about to ask you
what does it mean in late terms
so in late terms it means that we are
still running behind price increases
and if your budget is heavily
concentrated on food it is particularly
bad news for you
um the silver lining
it is coming down and it will continue
to come down we just hope it comes down
faster than it has so far
one of the prime minister's big targets
was to halve inflation this year do you
think he's on track
he will get that because Energy prices
are coming down
um economists have this very strange
notion of headline inflation what the
world gives you and then core inflation
what strips out the very volatile
features of inflation and that second
number is going to prove stickier than
most people would like
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you